the global Elites the government  whatever you want to call them they need  men to be weak fat and compliant because  when men are weak fat and compliant  they're easier to control and how are  they doing this by feminizing them by  telling them it's okay to be emotional  by telling them to share their feelings  but that's just not going to get you  anywhere in life that's not how a man  should be a man should be strong the  woman should be able to lean on a man he  should be able to provide and protect  for her so that she can then raise the  Next Generation and be nurturing whereas  he can then go out and conquer the world  and look after and protect her and so  when he is feminized the government can  then come in and take control of the  family there's no leadership anymore the  husband are supposed to lead the women  and the children in the correct  direction but if there's no leadership  there's a vacuum for the government to  come in and tell the family what to do